today is my man's 25th birthday
what have you done by the time you were
25 what did what had you done where were
you
what were you doing dude nothing right
nothing
i hadn't right at 25. just in case you
forgot
this is what he's done by 25. super bowl
champ
super bowl mvp 2018 nfl mvp
threw for 50 touchdowns that season
youngest qb to win a super bowl mvp
youngest to win mvp and super bowl first
qb with three 10-point comebacks in one
postseason and of course the biggest
contract in sports history but most
important as we both know
he's found a love of his life
congratulations you know 25 years old
you know going somewhere i see where you
go supremely talented
yeah you know gain we assume is gonna
just only slow down for him
we assume he's got he hasn't even
reached his full potential you see where
i'm going with this look
based on what you've seen to this point
are we in are we witnessing the
beginnings
of the career of the greatest
quarterback in nfl history when it's all
said and done
will patrick mahomes go down as the
greatest based on how we started his
career
oh see those are two different things
though those are two different
categories let me just start
at the beginning let's go to the front
door as james brown said let's go way
back there back to the beginning all
right so
is he the best at the age of 25
i think unquestionably yes at 25 years
old
you look at some of these numbers mike
you look at the ability
you look at his comfort level i mean you
were going down that list
and i and my mind went back to i think
it was third and fifteen
in the super bowl they were down ten
points at that point right was it twenty
to ten
look the details a little foggy at this
point but i think it was twenty to ten
third and fifteen
they're trailing san francisco in the
super bowl and he kind of lost it up
there
big gain to tyree kill and as we know
they made a big comeback and they won
the super bowl
i mean he's just so calm in these big
situations you think about
the comeback against the texans it's
relentless he just does
everything i'm trying to look for a
negative with patrick mahomes and i
can't find one so at the age of 25
i think he's better than anybody who's
played the game
at 25. now if you say the best of all
time
is it is he is he on his way i think he
got my questions confused and he
is he on his way when it's all said and
done assuming he stays healthy
yeah it's too hard to say that because
now you're asking me what's patrick
mahomes going to be in five years
because he needs to put in he needs to
put in a lot of work to be the best of
all time
unless you and this is where i got to
come back to how you think how your mind
is working we can get inside the mind
being michael smith
let me get inside the mind see how it
works
will you give somebody credit for being
the best of all time
let's say they play eight years let's go
with the gail sales
sayers argument can you be an all-time
great
if you have six seven eight years of
brilliance and then you stop
see you're speaking my love language
right now because i love nuance
i love splitting hairs so okay good the
goat is tom brady
all right he checks all the boxes and
long ago
brady put to rest the notion that he was
a system guy
or that he didn't have the ability of
some others
he checks all the boxes okay he's the
undisputed it's like in boxing he's
united all the belts right
right so he's a goat also the most
decorated
which has a lot to do with goat
conversations which goes into your point
about longevity often longevity and most
decorated go hand in hand
i told you yesterday the baddest man in
his peak for me
was steve young at his peak i'll take
his peak over just about anybody's
but the best to ever agrees with you by
the way
nobody in san francisco agrees the best
to ever
throw the football the best to ever
throw the football that i've seen
when you want to talk about talent
accomplishments that's aaron rodgers
and so right now for me aaron rodgers
talk about the arc
you talk about just the way the ball
looks in the air
accuracy almost every
he's the best to play the position no
he's the best to play the position
in terms of executing the position aaron
rodgers is the best
to play the position that i've seen i
love steve young
but in terms of just like the totality
of his career the numbers everything
it's painful the best that i've ever i
know so i'm saying i know i'm saying a
lot there what i'm seeing in patrick
mahomes
you know that's hurting me you're
hurting me you're hurting me right now
why
why am i hurting your feelings why
because you're saying the best to play
the position
part of playing the position is it's
every it's a totality position right so
it's it's about leadership it's about
accuracy
it's about winning it's about longevity
i i i factor
all those things in there so uh aaron
rodgers has some of them
and so if you say okay the best deep
ball maybe that's russell wilson maybe
that's aaron rodgers maybe that's warren
moon i don't know
the best the way the best the ball is in
the air back to warren moon and aaron
rodgers
but you said the best to play the
position now that's quarterbacking
that's a total
that's a total package aaron rodgers is
not the best quarterback i've ever seen
play
is best quarterback in the nfl right now
no is aaron rodgers the best quarterback
i've seen
you just started off talking about
patrick mahomes now you're talking
you're saying aaron rodgers is the best
you've seen played a position
right yes to this point i'm saying
patrick mahomes has a lot of aaron
rodgers
in him i'm sorry sorry if i'm confusing
you let me try to be more clear
in terms of somebody playing the
position okay
okay i think you're condescending i'll
take your condescension on a thursday
that's right no no that might
that no that might be me that wasn't
that wasn't there wasn't a referendum on
your comprehension skills that might be
me
maybe i'm just saying maybe i'm talking
in circles i don't know what i'm trying
to tell you is
aaron rodgers is the best to play the
position tom brady is the goat
obviously based on six super bowls
longevity the numbers
his ability all that stuff okay but the
best to play the position in terms of is
a pure passer maybe that's the words i'm
not saying as a pure
passer to me when you combine ability
with accomplishments with success all of
it it's
it's it's aaron rodgers for me patrick
mahomes i think to answer my own
question
if he continues on this path you know
given what he's already done at such a
short time i mean i don't remember if
aaron rodgers was playing by the time he
was 25 years old
and so if if patrick mahomes continues
on this path
i think patrick mahomes has a great shot
of going down
as the greatest ever you mentioned
russell wilson will get to him later
he may not be the best in the league
right now you look at ronda still four
touchdowns with his so-called air
apparent on the sideline
maybe aaron rodgers is still the best
right now but it's funny that we having
this conversation this very
nuanced you know uh you know
conversation has a lot of different
layers
you know to it or whatever it feels like
a top five mc conversation almost it's
like who's the best mc of all time
well i mean is that based off of record
sales is that longevity
i mean just who's
great but everybody's got their own
criteria for it somebody will
some people will just go who is who has
the best flow who's got the best bars
who's got the best lyrics
who's done it at the highest level
everybody like that's why it's like i
never like to get in who are the best
five i say who are my favorite five mcs
because best five that's what stars
fights yeah it does start fights now
with mahomes let's say this i i want to
get this uh
get this out if mahomes
keeps up this production which is
staggering he's got great numbers
he does a lot of things very well if
mahomes keeps this
up any but he
doesn't win another championship i don't
care about that
no you don't care wait i'll let you
finish the question go ahead
no i'm saying but if he doesn't win
another championship but he has the
numbers but just one championship
does that qualify in the michael smith
calculus
because you and i are getting to know
each other as tv partners
our audience is getting to know us as
a show the answer is an emphatic no i am
not a
wins guy and i am not a championships
guy
when it comes to individuals in team
sports
yes it can add to your resume but it is
not the determining and deciding factor
as to how i've used somebody i i grew up
in the gym
i was there was a book in my library in
my elementary school that i used to i
was the only person checked out i
remember the library back in the day
and you had you know the the little card
in the back that would have people's
names and the data got checked out that
little
little manila folder in the back of the
book my name was
the only name checking out this little
paperback book called yay big
it's every time and it was dan marino
versus joe montana
i was always a moreno guy i didn't care
about montana super bowls
i was always a merino guy okay that's
that was the first jersey i owned
was a dolphins dan marino jersey so i
have whether it's
pro football pro basketball i do not
judge people according to championships
in a team sport because taking nothing
away from tom brady's greatness
but how many super bowls did he lose
through no fault of his own
and how many super bowls did he win
based on plays
at the end of game at the end of games
with him on the sideline watching
that's interesting all these years i've
been knowing you mike how many years is
it let me just touch your memory here
first 20 years
20 years all right
21. go ahead what uh i'm sorry i'm going
to i just i'm looking i'm checking out
dm's go ahead what you got
all right all these years i've been
knowing you i didn't know that you felt
that way just in the in the montana
dan marino argument because i'm just
yeah i'm not even trying to mess with
you man i'm not even trying to troll you
i'm just the opposite like i was always
joe montana
back when they were posters on walls
kids still have posters on walls i don't
even know
i don't think my kids don't fat hairs
but back in the posters on the wall day
days
i had you know joe montana i had
living color at bob marley anyway but
joe montana was my guy joe montana was
the dude
and i can tell you i had no idea
what his numbers were i just knew that
joe in a tough situation
was going to get it done now as i went
back as i got older
and looked back at the numbers i i felt
like some of my anecdotal
evidence kind of broke down on me
because joe didn't always get it done
and joe
joe lost some divisional championship
games and some conference championships
but i just felt
like with the quarterback position it's
almost like the school bus driver
is everything cool are we okay
is everything in your hands all right
god i got it and joe montana always had
it now let me just move on though hey
can i move yeah no hold on hold on hold
on we got we get what you got we got a
different we got a direct message coming
from
our producer gary who is begging us to
get to this direct message
because it's a dc guy and he felt
compelled
to get this in the show somehow because
he's like oh y'all showing
love to patrick mahomes on his birthday
how about my guy
alexander ovechkin says gary he didn't
say all of that i know that's what he
was thinking when he sent this direct
message better athlete born today
are a veteran my home
look at that oh they even cut ovechkin
video for this okay
[Laughter]
then we're gonna get this in the show
come hella hot water
this was getting in the show one way out
because one thing nbc has michael one
thing nbc has
is hockey video well we got some stock
shout outs shout out to my people what's
up katherine tappin
hey what's going on answered carter
that's not the question though answer
answer this question which one the whole
best kid better athlete it's my homes
it's my homes look three mvps
profession says gary in my ear
overacting is great
olessa's great but um and i was so happy
for him
when he finally won nobody enjoyed the
stanley cup
journey as much as alexander ovechkin it
took him a long time
he took some undue criticism i'll give
him that because a lot of people blamed
him
for the capitals shortcomings but
i can't say definitively right now oh no
question
uh ovechkin even when they won was
ovechkin no question the best player in
the nhl no i mean he's good i mean he's
excellent
is ovechkin better than cindy crosby you
know
i don't know i don't know but patrick
holmes at the age of 25 was just
record setting that's it i got it it's
my homes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports